le confinement créer de la solidarité
mais pas partout cette histoire est
assez incroyable nadja a contracté le
kobe 19
elle a été hospitalisée chez elle ment
20e arrondissement de paris et ses
voisins ne l'ont pas aidé non ils lui
ont demandé de quitter les lieux par
peur d'être contaminés elle est en
direct avec nous nadja est elle est là
pour me raconter son histoire
la jaa bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors comment tu as
des vous êtes-vous guéri alors je ne
suis pas tout à fait guéri disons que je
pense j'ai passé le plus dur
j'ai passé là la phase critique
maintenant il faut que je me repose et
que je je je laisse passer un peu de
temps pour pouvoir retrouver des forces
mais je pense pas on m'a prévenu que ce
serait un peu l'eau donc maintenant ces
deux-là de la patience en fait donc vous
êtes vous êtes hospitalisé à chez vous
avec une infirmière qui vient votre
domicile alors tout à fait en fait grâce
à grâce à des mesures prises par mon
employeur via la mutuelle que nous avons
nous avons eu la possibilité de trouver
ce moyen c'est-à-dire de ne pas prendre
un lit comme je suis seul chez moi je ne
peux pas contaminer quelqu'un autour de
moi et donc c'était aussi une solution
peut-être pour moi pour être mieux est
d'avoir une infirmière qui venait
régulièrement inspectés alors naître
racontez nous un peu ce qui s'est passé
je disais à votre histoire est assez
incroyable votre voisinage a été on peut
le dire très égoïstes qui vous a demandé
de quitter votre domicile par peur
d'être contaminés que vous avez même
reçu un message de votre syndic
oui tout à fait en fait moi je n'ouvrais
pas la porte mais l'infirmière elle
allait et venait de son propre chef avec
les clés et un sou nous avons trouvé un
mot coincé dans la porte qui me disait
que étant donné que l'appartement était
au rez-de-chaussée
c'était un passage pour tout l'immeuble
j'ai représenté un danger pour le reste
de la copropriété et qu'il fallait que
je quitte mon appartement
donc au lieu de vous aider un c'est ce
qui se fait en général quand quelqu'un
souffre quand on sait que quelqu'un est
malade et de surcroît comme vous seul
chez vous en tout cas ce n'est pas ce
qui a été fait par votre voisinage
est ce que vous savez une hantise aimant
qui sont les voisins qui souhaitaient
votre départ alors je ne sais pas en
fait précisément qui sont les voisins
qui souhaitaient le départ
ce que je sais c'est que ils savent tous
que je suis seul dans un appartement je
n'habite pas j'ai l'appartement depuis
cinq ans ils savent exactement qui je
suis et quelles sont mes conditions de
vie puisque j'ai le plus petit
appartement aussi de l'immeuble
c'est un appartement qui est qui qui
était que les autres copropriétaires
voulait récupérer quand moi je les
achetais et et du coup je n'ai pas
toujours été très bien accueilli et là
en fait je pense voir qui cela peut être
l'imaginent
j'ai contacté le syndic le syndic
en fait on m'a expliqué qu'ils étaient
obligés de me faire savoir qu'il y avait
une plainte
par contre en off mais moi je ne tiens
pas ce que ça ça reste of j'avais le
droit effectivement de porter plainte
contre la copropriété donc c'est ce que
je vais faire deux je pense porter
plainte contre la copropriété parce que
au delà de mon atteinte personnelle et
de la condition dans laquelle je suis je
pense que les autres propriétaires
n'imagine pas c'est à dire que je ne
peux pas sortir de chez moi j'ai vu
personne depuis le 30 mars je ne parle
avec personne si ce n'est mon boss au
téléphone que l'appartement n'est pas
entretenu parce que je ne suis pas
capable
il ya aussi cette infirmière
qui du coup avait un peu peur de venir
me voir je considère que c'est une
entrave
oui bien public elle à l'entr'aide à ce
qui se dresse ce plat de passer en cas
de gros pour grosse problématique
mondiale même les gens devraient
s'entraider et au lieu de ça en fait les
personnes qui sont soit défavorisé par
rapport à l'autre soit par rapport à
leur situation et bien en fait selon
nous à mal donc j'ai eu
j'ai été d'abord déçu triste mais
maintenant je suis un peu effrayée je
dois reconnaître de porter plainte parce
que j'ai peur qu'il s'en suivre d'autres
choses comme je ne suis je ne pèse pas
lourd dans la copropriété et ça presque
une question pour moi donc
nadja aujourd'hui vous avez envie de
rester dans votre immeuble malgré le
comportement de vos voisins
non non clairement bon j'attends de voir
comment se passe économiquement la
reprise de mon emploi je sais que mon
boss fait tout pour que pour conserver
les emplois les salaires je ne pense pas
que ce soit possible mais en tout cas
les emplois mais j'étais en période
d'essai en fait quand la la pandémie a
commencé donc que j'attends de voir
comment ça va se passer parce que
j'avais vraiment être confirmées ou pas
et je pense que je vendrai l'appartement
et je partirai mais je ne pourrais pas
rester non mais c'est compliqué de vivre
à côté d'un voisinage si peu
bienveillant nadja merci pour votre
témoignage on vous souhaite un très bon
rétablissement et bon courage et
malheureusement 8000 votre cas n'est pas
isolé lui a même une infirmière dans le
loir qui a décidé tout comme vous elle
aussi de saisir la justice parce que son
voisinage il a demandé de quitter les
lieux merci nadja merci beaucoup